après vous avoir parlé du Galaxy A54 5G
le jour vous a donné mon retour complet
le test qu'on peut dire vous savez tout
bref sur ma chaîne youtube et bien on va
venir continuer dans cet univers avec
aujourd'hui le à 34 5G qui est un
smartphone vous vous en doutez ça c'est
plutôt bien qui est un smartphone dans
le milieu du milieu de gamme voilà donc
ce que là vous êtes aujourd'hui dans le
milieu de gamme à 14 5G il y a également
le 14 4G mais on en parle pas on va
plutôt se concentrer sur le A14 5G le
A34 bien évidemment 5G puis bien
évidemment le A54 5G dont on a déjà
parlé donc aujourd'hui on se regarde
celui-là vous allez voir il est super
intéressant surtout il y a vraiment se
positionner entre les deux alors je sais
que c'est un petit peu facile à vous
dire ça visuellement comme ça mais il
fait plein de jolies promesses on va
donc regarder s'il les tiens au niveau
de tout ce qui va être multimédia ce qui
va être intéressant pour un des films
des séries est-ce qu'il conviendra là
dessus sans aucun problème est-ce qu'il
va être également performant pour le
gaming pour venir jouer à des jeux sur
mobile qu'est-ce que ça raconte du côté
photo parce que vous le voyez ici bien
vous avez de toute façon trois capteurs
partout donc qu'est-ce qui devient vous
raconter c'est A34 5G est-ce qu'il est
intéressant à quel tarif il est et au
final est-ce qu'il faut venir l'acheter
vous êtes prêt allez c'est parti
[Musique]
alors on enlève les autres c'est pas les
produits qui nous intéressent tout de
suite on va vraiment se concentrer sur
ce smartphone là alors la première chose
à venir voir avec ce smartphone et c'est
vraiment le truc qui est très
intéressant c'est l'uniformisation du
design regardez c'est smartphone soit
ressemblent énormément avec ici le plus
haut de gamme le milieu de gamme est
vraiment l'entrée de gamme dans ce
milieu de gamme vous voyez je sais pas
vous avez pas trop largué là-dessus donc
on a vraiment des designs qui ressemble
aujourd'hui au Galaxie S23 qui sont les
smartphones les plus haut de gamme le
design ici est très sympa vous avez un
grand écran alors à la différence de ce
que vous allez venir retrouver au niveau
du Galaxy A54 et bien ici vous allez
avoir vous le voyez sur le haut une
espèce de petit encoche dans laquelle va
venir se mettre votre caméra sinon c'est
la même chose au niveau des bordures
alors le truc à venir savoir également
ici c'est que l'écran fait 6,6 pouces un
peu plus grand que le 6,4 pouces du 1 à
54 5G vous avez pour autant une dalle
Super AMOLED très lumineuse qui va
jusqu'à 1000 litres donc pour tout ce
qui va être contenu regarder en
extérieur ça ira très très bien vous
avez en plus de ça un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 120
Hertz donc ça c'est très cool sur la
fluidité des mouvements ici ça
conviendra parfaitement bien donc ça
c'est le premier point pour tout ce qui
va être visionnage de films de série
vous avez une dalle qui est vraiment
bien maîtrisée par Samsung le Super
AMOLED est très bien c'est lumineux ça
va aussi bien en intérieur qu'en
extérieur alors on a des haut-parleurs
stéréo ici qui sont pas mal ce que je
vous recommande quand même c'est de
venir utiliser des écouteurs Bluetooth
ça sera beaucoup mieux pour vous et pour
vos oreilles puisque même si on a un son
qui est pas dégueu en stéréo ça tire un
peu vers le médium et c'est pas
extrêmement agréable et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que jusqu'au 31 avril
vous avez des Galaxy buds 2 qui sont
offerts si vous venez l'acheter
directement sur le site de Samsung alors
je vous mets un lien en bas sur le site
de Samsung si vous souhaitez vous faire
plaisir vous le trouverez ce smartphone
j'ai tarifs là où tu arrives de 399
euros sur la version 6 giga de ram 128
Go de stockage et 469 euros sur la
version 8 Go de RAM 256 Go de stockage
attention c'est top avec les galaxies
buzz 2 c'est uniquement jusqu'au 30
avril 2023 donc pour tout ce qui va être
multimédia ça conviendra bien maintenant
la question c'est niveau gaming alors
regardez niveau gaming ça fonctionne
quand même plutôt pas mal aussi on a pas
le processeur le plus performant ici
soyons clairs on est sur un dynens city
1080 de médiathèque processeur 5G bien
évidemment qui conviendra pour faire
tourner plein de jeux ici je suis sur
asphalt 9 c'est bien ça fonctionne c'est
fluide donc pas de mauvaise surprise ça
réagit également très très bien donc on
peut faire tourner quand même pas mal de
jeux du Play Store donc une fois de plus
pour l'univers de gaming ici pas de
mauvaise surprise ça ira bien alors il
faut savoir qu'ici moi je suis sur la
version 6 Go de RAM 128 Go de stockage
mais peut-être vous allez vous craquer
pour la version 8 Go de RAM 250 giga de
stockage alors je vous le dis déjà comme
il est là aussi giga de ram
personnellement je vais pas trouver
kiram il est efficace il fonctionne bien
donc il suit pas une mauvaise surprise
tout en sachant qu'il est extensible au
niveau du stockage jusqu'à 1 t donc ça
c'est plutôt bien aussi alors la
question de l'autonomie vous allez me
dire et on a ici une grosse batterie de
5000 milliampères heure donc pas de
mauvaise surprise c'est une batterie qui
tiendra bien un jour et demi ça va te
dépendre une fois de plus de vous et de
vos usages d'autonomie est bonne on peut
venir le recharger jusqu'à 25 watts
exactement comme sur le A54 5G donc
voyez il y a quand même beaucoup de
similitudes entre ce smartphone là et
celui-ci même taille de la batterie même
charge rapide 25 même si effectivement
on peut avoir plus rapide que du 25
watts mais ça fait quand même le taf
donc pour l'instant la grosse différence
qu'on va venir retrouver entre ces deux
smartphones et bien ça va vraiment être
le processeur on aura un pro ce qui sera
un peu moins puissant sur le A34 que sur
le à 54 tout en sachant et ça c'est
vachement bien vous avez 4 ans de mise à
jour Android là on est sur Android 13
vous aurez le 14 le 15 le 16 le 17 et 5
années de mise à jour de sécurité donc
vous êtes vraiment tranquille pour
l'avenir donc si vous achetez
aujourd'hui ce smartphone et que vous
voulez le garder pendant 4 ans vous
aurez les dernières mises à jour ça
conviendra bien alors pour autant est-ce
qu'arrivera un moment ou peut-être que
les jeux rameront davantage dessus c'est
totalement possible mais en tout cas en
terme de mise à jour une mise à jour de
sécurité vous êtes tranquille pendant
minimum 4 ans alors l'autre point qui
est intéressant c'est tout ce qui se
passe au niveau de la partie photo parce
que vous avez trois caméras et vous
allez
le ventre le a que vous avez là le A54
que vous avez là et le A14 5G vous avez
là et bien vous avez beau avoir trois
caméras ce ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
caméras et on va pas du tout aller sur
la même chose enfin pas du tout à
quelque chose près sur le A34 5G vous le
voyez vous avez une caméra grand angle
de 48 mégapixels avec une stabilisation
optique je précise parce que c'est pas
le cas sur le 14 mais on en parle dans
une autre vidéo vous avez un capteur
ultra grand-angle de 8 mégapixels où
vous avez du 12 mégapixels sur le A54 et
vous avez pas le tout doux très grand
angle sur le 14 5G mais ça c'est encore
une autre histoire et vous avez la même
caméra de macro que le A54 avec un
capteur de 5 mégapixels alors j'ai
vraiment pas que vous soyez déçu ici on
est sur le milieu de gamme du milieu de
gamme donc on va pas avoir un truc de
fou furieux au niveau des photos mais si
vous regardez sur le grand angle le en
effet c'est très correct alors pour
autant c'est pas là où on va voir la
meilleure précision et le meilleur piqué
mais c'est correct tandis que l'ultra
grand temps que sera un peu moins fou ça
va être assez saturé très honnêtement
vous voyez ici je trouve que là mais
quand même très très verte et le ciel
très très bleu et là vous voyez on a un
peu de violine qui arrive et voyons bon
c'est un peu la limite du truc et puis
après on a du zoom numérique x 2 x 4 pas
jusqu'au x 10 c'est totalement numérique
ici et vous allez voir que on perd
énormément en piqué c'est pas beau c'est
pas bien défini les couleurs sont pas
très très naturelles là il y a une
couleur au niveau de la façade qu'on a
pas réellement côté un peu jaunâtre donc
bon c'est pas parfait et vous venez vous
rapprocher vous voyez qu'à la fin c'est
franchement dégueulasse là c'est pareil
sur un petit contre jour ça fonctionne
ça vient bien me ressortir les branches
c'est globalement assez honnête même si
c'est très saturé mais ça une fois de
plus c'est un peu ce qu'on va retrouver
de façon un peu général chez Samsung
ultra grand angle on passe c'est
beaucoup trop saturé et on vient zoomer
mais en fait non on vient pas zoomer
c'est dégueulasse pareil là sur le grand
angle ça fait le taf avec une vraie
stabilisation optique une fois de plus
je tiens vraiment à le préciser ça ça
marche l'ultra grand-angle on évite même
si on peut quand même sortir des choses
mais c'est pas très très joli vous voyez
grand angle ultra grand-angle et après
voilà c'est ni fait ni à faire là pour
photographier des plantes c'est assez
sympa la gestion des Lumières est pas
mauvaise même si on voit qu'il a un
petit peu mal là ici au niveau de haute
lumière mais une fois de plus on est sur
un smartphone un peu moins de 400 balles
donc c'est pas déconnant vous voyez
après les mêmes critiques là c'est
pareil c'est plutôt sympa ça fonctionne
bon et après on évite de venir zoomer la
caméra de selfie s'en sort pas trop mal
regardez là un soleil de côté je trouve
que c'est assez naturel au niveau du
rendu du visage la lumière du soleil est
vraiment très très forte et pour autant
je ne suis pas cramé même dans les
cheveux donc bon ça fait le taf sur un
contre jour on voit bien le boulot il
est aussi bien fait avec le soleil juste
là bon alors bien évidemment là je
cherche vraiment la petite bête mais ça
reste quand même correct donc ici pas de
mauvaise surprise au niveau de vos
selfies le mode macro alors très
honnêtement je vous le dis il vous met
trois caméras histoire de dire tiens
c'est bien il y a trois caméras mais ça
ça sert globalement à rien parce que
vous sortez de la macro ouais mais sur
du 5 mégapixels c'est pas très joli on a
du mal à trouver la bonne distance on se
rapproche pas énormément son quoi c'est
pas terrible et voilà moi je suis
globalement pas fan ici mais c'est pas
nouveau tous ces capteurs de macros qui
viennent vous mettre en 5 mégapixels de
mégapixels pour moi on oublie même si tu
reconnais que ces petites fleurs bleues
là sont quand même très jolies en plus
de ça c'est un smartphone qui est
certifié résistant il y a l'eau à
poussière avec une certification
IP67 pas IP68 mais IP67 ça fera déjà le
boulot en plus de ça vous avez un verre
Corning Gorillaz 5 donc le smartphone
est résistant et ça c'est aussi
rassurant même si une fois de plus ce
n'est pas la dernière génération de
Corning goriagas ce Galaxy A34 5G donc
un smartphone
surprise qui fait le taf mais qui n'en
fait pas trop qui n'en fait pas trop peu
non plus qui est bien positionné une
fois de plus dans le milieu du milieu de
gamme niveau photo le grand angle la
fractaf l'écran est vraiment d'une très
jolie qualité avec cette dalle Super
AMOLED qui est très bien très lumineuse
et qui vous conviendra parfaitement bien
qui va jusqu'à 120 pour le gaming le
processeur n'est pas le plus performant
mais une fois de plus il conviendra
également pour faire tourner beaucoup de
jeux du Play Store et pour toutes vos
applications pour regarder vos films vos
séries il y a pas de ralentissement ça
marche les applications se lancent
rapidement donc ici je trouve ça aussi
assez efficace et ça fonctionne bien
donc ça ça me va donc on est sur un
smartphone voyez qui a 399 € dans la
version 628 et 469 euros dans la version
8 256 et globalement très honnête et
c'est un smartphone que je peux venir
vous recommander vous n'aurez pas de
mauvaise surprise ici il va pas être
extraordinaire mais tout ce qui fait il
le fait quand même plutôt bien donc ça
c'est bien alors aussi petit détail à
venir connaitre vous n'avez pas de blocs
de charge inclus à l'intérieur qu'il
faut venir acheter en supplément si vous
voulez bénéficier de la charge rapide 25
watts même si c'est pas la plus rapide
du monde quand même très bien et bien il
faut acheter ce bloc de charge en plus
sur le site de Samsung une fois de plus
je vous mets tous les liens sont des
liens d'affiliation en bas par la
description et puis n'oubliez pas
l'offre de lancement jusqu'au 30 avril
s'il vous intéresse vous avez les
galaxies buzz 2 offert pour venir
maximiser l'expérience et moi cette
petite couleur s'appelle comment c'est
là où sommes violet et bien que je
trouve pas mal alors après petit info
juste à guise d'information le A34 est
fabriqué en Inde vous voyez c'est écrit
ici une or sur blanc c'est exactement la
même chose si vous prenez le A54 tandis
que le A14 5G lui est fabriqué en Chine
voilà je sais pas si ça vous intéresse
de connaître la provenance de vos
produits de savoir où ils sont fabriqués
mais en fait ce que ça montre c'est que
a priori et je veux pas me tromper en
disant ça je pense que c'est exactement
la même usine qui va vous fabriquer le
A54 et le A34 donc le cahier des charges
doit être très proche de la part de
Samsung c'est pour ça que ces deux
smartphones sont quand même relativement
similaires même si le processeur va être
plus performant ici même techno d'écran
et on voit qu'effectivement une
différence avec ce A14 5G mais celui-là
je vous en parle dans une autre vidéo
très très bientôt comme ça vous saurez
tous sur ce smartphone qui coûte quand
même 249 euros mais ça on en parle bien
évidemment une prochaine fois donc à
vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez de
ce smartphone de ce à 34 5G est-ce que
vous aimez bien le design est-ce que
vous aimez cette couleur j'adore cette
couleur est-ce qu'il pourrait vous
tenter bien évidemment vous marquer ça
en bas dans les commentaires et nous on
se retrouve très bientôt pour continuer
à parler de Samsung et notamment du à 14
5G je vous embrasse prenez soin de vous
et à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]